en premier jacques sauvageot étant donné
le poids vous avez pendant cette période
et qu'est-ce que vous recherchiez au
départ enchaîne les branlées
l'université ou ébranlé le monde en
passant à l'université c'était pas plus
pour étudiants comme le mouvement
ouvrier qu'il va péter dans un contexte
très politisé contestation du
capitalisme les protestations du
socialisme réel
je trouve que la présentation qu'il ya
là de leur présente pas ce qui s'est
passé en mai 68 on peut dire c'est le
début mais le mouvement de mai 68 ça
avec ap général c'est le fait que des
millions de personnes se sont mis en
grève pendant trois semaines y compris
ne voulait pas reprendre le travail bien
coloré accorder des revendications
salariales des augmentations de salaire
qui est extrêmement important
ce qui est important c'est pas le
mouvement étudiant c'est le mouvement
ouvrier moi c'est effectivement ce
développement d'un mouvement généralisé
dans les dents l'université dans les
quartiers dans les entreprises à la
campagne partout c'est ce qui fait mai
68 à pramont n'en parlerai pas
[Musique]